ست العميد اذا ما علقنا على كلام هل يمكن
لهذه الحرب بالفعل ان تستمر عقودا
لا نتحدث عن العقود ولكن الاكيد ان هذه
الحرب لن تنتهي عثمان هذه السنه والدليل
على ذلك ان الفريقان يتحضران للمرحله
القادمه
زياده الانتاج العسكري الروسي
التطويع المزيد ومنهم من يقول ان بامكانيه
روسيه 2.4 مليون من الجنود ولا نزل في
المرحله العسكريه التي لم تحسم بعد يعني
لم نصل الى مرحله قد يذهب او يقتنع
الطرفان بالذهاب الى طاوله التفاوض حتى
الامريكيون يقولون انه لن نذهب الى طاوله
تفاوض الا بموافقه اوكرانيه وهذا الامر
ليس متوفرا ولكن ما قاله الرئيس مدفداب هو
فعلا يعكس ما يريد ويقول الرئيس بوتين
ولكن كيف يمكن ان يقتنع الطرفان بان يذهب
الى طاوله المفاوضات ان كان كل ما حدث
خاصه على الجانب الاوكراني لم يقنعهما بان
يذهب الى طاوله
يعني ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث عسكريا اكثر
مما حدث
يعني قد يذهب الاوكراني الى ضرب الجسر
البري وهذا امر مستبعد حاليا بناء لما
نشرته ان الاستخبارات الامريكيه تقول من
الصعب الوصول حتى الى مليتو بول فاذا
اليوم هذا امر مهم اثنين الاستنزاف عثمان
شيء مهم جدا يعني اليوم الجيش الروسي
مستنزف العتاد الروسي مستنزف وفي نفس
الوقت العتاد الغربي بالرغم من حداثته لا
يكفي كي تحقق اوكرانيا
ما تريد ان تحققه على الاقل الخرق او على
الاقل تحرير الارض الاوكرانيه قد نصل الى
مرحله ما يسمى بستيل ميت وقد نصل الى
النموذج الكوري على ان تكون هناك ليس وقت
للحرب ستيل ميت او وقف للنار لفتره طويله
وعليه تبدا حلول سياسيه على المدى الطويل
اوكرانيا ترسل مسيراتها الى موسكو وسبق
وان وصفت هذه الضربات بانها
ضربات سيكولوجيه او رمزيه او يمكن ان يكون
لها تاثير نفسي ولكن سؤالي هل يمكن ان
يتطور الامر اكثر من ذلك هل لدى اوكرانيا
القدره على ان تطور قدراته العسكريه بما
تحمله
بما تحمله من ارث او بما ورثته حتى عن عن
روسيا نفسها من قدرات في الجانب العسكري
عثمان 200 شركه كانت ايام الاتحاد
السوفيتي تزود روسيا بالعتاد العسكري
اوكرانيا كانت تزود قبل الحرب بالتسعينات
ما بعدها الصين حتى بالعتاد العسكري لديهم
ما يقارب 375 الف من المبرمجين يعني لدى
اوكرانيا صناعات عسكريه متقدمه محركات
الطوافات حتى
البارجه موسكو التي اغرقت هي بنيت في
مايكلف ومؤخرا تم قصف معمل سيرش العسكري
للمحركات في ذا فروجيا وهو الذي يزود
الطائرات المسيرات التركيه
بالمحركات فاذا نحن امام مرحله قادره على
صنعنا المرحله القاعده العلميه موجوده
والقاعده الصفط وير كما يقال ايضا موجوده
ولكن هذا امر يتطلب وقت ان يتطلب الاعداد
التخطيط التجربه ومن ثم
الانتاج الكثيف والاستعمال وهذا امر يتطلب
وقت عثمان من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا
لك